♪♪♪♪
-These are two of our writers --
Amber and Jenny.
-I'm black!
-And I'm gay!
-And we're both women.
-And I'm not!
So here's how this works.
I'll read the setups
for these jokes,
and Amber and Jenny
will read the punch lines.
Here we go.
A Catholic man recently
wrote a book called
"Why I Don't Call Myself Gay."
-Look for it in the closet
of your local bookstore.
[ Laughter ]
-A black tourist in Amsterdam
was recently pushed down
the stairs by her Airbnb host.
-It was the best experience
a black person has had
with Airbnb.
-Have you had
bad experiences on Airbnb?
-As soon as someone lets me stay
with them, I'll let you know.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm fine. I have a house.
-According to a recent study,
the average number of guests
at a lesbian wedding is 87.
-It's 2 brides
and 85 ex-girlfriends.
-Jenny, what's
a lesbian wedding like?
-Well, it's just like
a straight wedding,
except instead of rice
you throw power tools.
-Oh, cool.
A Virginia teenager
recently became
the first African-American boy
to be named valedictorian
of his high school.
-But he'll still be tried
as an adult.
[ Audience groans ]
-[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
-If it was up to them,
you'd lose that house.
-[ Laughs ]
I meant apartment.
[ Laughter ]
-I was gonna say...
I know what I pay you.
[ Laughter ]
A new study claims
that millennials
are having a hard time
saving money
because they're eating out
too much.
-"No such thing," said lesbians.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Jenny's winning.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-A military officer
born in Ghana
recently became
Queen Elizabeth's
first close black adviser.
-Or as the queen calls him,
"Uh, driver..."
[ Laughter ]
-According to a recent article,
the newest gay icon
is the horror-movie character
the Babadook.
-While the lesbian icon
is still the birkenstock.
-Are birkenstocks really
the ultimate lesbian icon?
-No, the ultimate lesbian icon
is your haircut.
-Oh, hey.
The Maddow.
The city of Rochester, New York,
recently hired their first
black female firefighter.
-And their Dalmatian
will not stop barking at her!
Hey, Seth, you know how you can
tell she's a black firefighter?
-How?
-She carries an ask.
[ Man laughs loudly ]
[ Light laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
-It's just you, brother!
-I get it!
-You and me, baby!
-Did you find the one person?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You see,
black people say "ax."
So then if they're carrying
an ax, they would say "ask."
[ Light laughter ]
Still no?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-The Chinese government
recently shut down
the country's most popular
lesbian dating app.
-A lesbian dating app
is like a regular dating app,
except you swipe like this.
-Ohh.
Wait. Did I get that right?
All right. Cool.
And how long
do you have to do it?
-As long as she wants.
-Okay, great. Yeah.
According to a recent article,
the number of black students
at Harvard Law School
dropped significantly last year.
-A black Harvard student is like
a white Harvard student,
except when he says,
"Do you know who my father is?"
he's really asking.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I'm sorry to correct you,
but I think he's axing.
-[ Laughs ]
-Hey, Seth,
why don't you tell one?
-Oh, I don't think
I should, Jenny!
-You got to, bud!
-I don't think
I'll get away with it!
-Oh, come on! Do it!
-Okay, guys.
-What could go wrong?
-If you promise
nothing will go wrong.
-I promise.
-Yeah!
-The black-ensemble movie
"Girls Trip"
had the largest opening
of any live-action comedy
so far this year,
beating the previous record
for largest opening, yo mama.
-How dare you?!
-You told me I could say it!
-You should be ashamed
of yourself!
-Lesbians and black women
are liars!
♪♪♪♪
We'll be right back with
more "Late Night," everybody.